you can hire someone on demand
which is uh qualified for the job
but is not actually on your payroll
and this is something incredible we're
doing so
think about that you can hire someone in
our platform
okay for one day
and we call it the try before you buy
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jvengers a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with ctec
hello hello and welcome to 20 minute
leaders today i have with me nir gold
co-founder and ceo at deeb
before starting deeb nir was a project
manager for several startups then later
decided to transition into business
development roles he was humbled to get
the opportunity to work at parallel
cohen law firm as an investment banker
where he launched an initiative to make
better connections between startups and
investors a year ago near was reminded
of an old idea he had that started out
as a small initiative in the field of
employment that later grew and evolved
into deep the idea to fundamentally
change the way employment is perceived
and the way people think about
employment in the 21st century
near gold welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you
well i'm excited to be here uh
and
i heard a lot about you so uh
thank you
thank you very very much for uh for
joining me
it's gonna be it's gonna be a lot of fun
and
are you calling from the deep offices
right now
that's true that's true uh
we're in deep office uh in tel aviv
uh we're based in the center of tel aviv
so it's an exciting place to be
very very cool
i i love it i i i think we might just be
a few streets away right now but i'm
excited to still do this
the way we're doing it nevertheless
tell me a little bit about yourself and
and then we'll get
deep into deeb
uh so basically i'm 27 years old i'm the
ceo and co-founder of dib
um
my background
i started um
as a you know as a combat soldier in
magazine unit uh
right after my service i uh
found myself in uh in
my first startup which was uh by a by
coincidence
uh i became a project manager in a
failing startup
and in this startup actually i realized
that
the business realm is the
is sometimes more important than the
product itself
um i saw many startups in my life that
they're focusing you know on the product
and they're really product oriented or
tech oriented but they're not focusing
on the business side so
right after that uh
after this chapter in my life i i jumped
into the business world which i started
my
uh let's call it my business development
career
uh
which i served in several uh
in several companies and
right after that i actually i got my
chance and my opportunity to join the
pearl column law firm
as an investment banker which was like
my
biggest jump in the business realm
and
actually this is the first time actually
i i felt and learned about the venture
capital world
and that was exciting to be honest
with with my old boss
i helped to connect lots of uh startups
into vcs and
investors and that was exciting
so from product
management to investment associates to
now co-founder and ceo how do you how do
you explain those those
you know changes
well my mother said i have
a lot of luck in my life so i don't know
uh i would say it's uh
it's about opportunities you need to
introduce the moment and
you can't afraid i mean sometimes
sometimes
things
might look you know too big for you but
you just need to you know
keep on and one of my biggest uh
things that actually i
need i need must learn now is that
something one of my old mentors said is
it's called ttp which means trust the
process
and just need to believe in that and
focus on that and just you know
very very cool that's basically
what i would say
so not just it's not just the jumps from
the titles that are
that are different but it's also the
sectors
right so you were you went from being a
project an operational manager at hebrew
scouts movement in israel
another pm before that to going to a law
firm and doing investment banking but
but now looking at an employing
employment marketplace how do you land
in the employment marketplace sector
especially targeting israeli the israeli
market
so i will say that the israeli market is
just our first step that's first thing
to understand uh we started in israel
because we are israelis so it's easier
to start here but we definitely aim for
a bigger market abroad
but i would say that
to understand the job market
you you don't necessarily have to be i
don't know
from an hr company or an hr uh position
because the biggest crisis the economy
facing today is gen z
won't fit into the the job market that's
the biggest crisis
and to understand that i would say that
uh
if you're not part of the gen z it will
be really hard for you to understand the
problem
so
what i would i will proudly say is that
most of the employees in our company are
young
so it's easier for them to understand
the next generation of of the job market
and in your in your mind what is this
next generation of of the job market
that you're describing here
so
um
listen we are j we are
gen z okay
and our generation works works
differently
and our generation demands flexibility
and not willing to compromise on
work-life balance and if someone
won't understand that it would be really
hard for them to hire people so that's
the first thing people need to
understand
and
and you know
there are many things that just work
differently for this for this generation
um
for instance they have
different needs as i said before they
they demand work-life balance they don't
want to
live their entire life
in their jobs they want to fulfill
themselves
they want flexibility
they want to have the ability to choose
what and where they're doing that and
this generation actually you know they
grew differently than how you know
gen y and x actually
were raised as when they were kids
so
that is a
fundamental
uh
change it's it's fundamental thing that
works differently for them and you know
they have different methods that they
grew up as kids and they brought that
into their work life
right
now as you're thinking through
if you're thinking through deeb
as an employment marketplace for
generation z and you're thinking through
the different
you know user behaviors and consumer
behaviors that that are shaping the
world now
how are you going about systematically
enabling implementing those within deep
so how do you know even how to
prioritize these changes
and how the product is going to look
down the line
um
it's a hard question i'll be honest uh
if you ask me how deep will look like i
don't know in 10 years from now and how
the job market will look in 10 years
from now it will be really hard to
answer that
uh i think uh the most important thing
is that
um
people need to remember that uh
the opposite of breakable is flexible
okay so we have to be flexible in
everything we do
this is how actually i manage the the
company
so everything we do here is flexible we
are hiring uh our our hiring process is
flexible
our methods are more flexible than what
most of the companies are doing
and
and i think all the employers or the
future employees have to uh to adapt
this flexible uh method
and deeb
basically was founded to enable you know
a straightforward and smooth transition
uh to this new marketplace for both
employers and employees and and enabling
both of the sides this flexibility
and this is actually the main thing
we're doing here
we are we believe that
the key element is
flexible
and so how does flexibility actually
come into play
from a product perspective so if we're
looking to
empower the flexibility
of the new employees and and the way
that we are interacting with with our
world and our work life balance
what is the what is the now so if that
is the shift in consumer behavior i mean
how is this now being translated into an
app that will help me as a gen z new
employee employee
you know have that interaction with my
work
so basically you know
deep is a shift on demand network
because we don't believe in a full-time
job we don't believe in a
in a nine-to-five job
and and generations is
is thinking the same and we know that uh
you know
because we we study this thing
and we you know
we
interview i think more than thousands of
of you know young people
and
most of them want this flexibility so
they
it's not that they're lazy they're not
lazy
they they want to work they want to work
differently
and and and this is why
there's a there's a huge gap between you
know let's call it the
the old employers to the new to the
future employees
and we're trying to
you know bridge this gap
by enabling this our i mean our platform
is here to enable that and we're helping
them
uh to communicate differently
our product as i said before it's a
shift on demand network where
we're giving the opportunity to
employers to
[Music]
divide the concept of job
into small shifts into microshifts
and then they can hire as many people as
they like
but with um
how do i say that uh
easier way to hire them and
everything is more simple we're
simplifying all the process with
simplifying
all the
the concept of hiring and simplifying
the
obligation from the from both sides
simplification on the employer side talk
to me about that because you not only
have to give a good experience for the
employee but you also have to
adjust for the employers needs to add
flexibility which oftentimes translates
into complexity for the employer right
true
um
i i would say first that we need to
understand that
there's a shift in power and we can see
you know the big
resignation now in the states or or how
people call the big quit
so
employees today first of all
i mean employers need to understand that
employees have more power than they used
to have in the past that the first thing
but and i'm saying but
uh
we don't want to for
to say you know this is the situation
and you have nothing to do so we got
some inspiration actually from the idf
and
you know the inspiration came from a
very unexpected place
and it's called the reserve unit
okay so if you think about the concept
of reserved unit in the idf
it's incredible
how so because you can hire people
because you can hire someone on demand
which is uh qualified for the job
but is not actually on your payroll
and this is something incredible we're
doing so
uh think about that you can hire someone
in our platform
okay for one day
and we call it the try before you buy so
you can try first
and if you if if this match is not good
enough
and to be honest it doesn't matter for
for this matter it doesn't matter why
but if it doesn't work
you you can just go and that's okay but
if there's a click if there's a match
it's a good match
you can you know add this guy to your
let's call it your favorite divers
and
now you can call him again but again
it's not on your payroll you can hire
him again you know as i said it's shift
on demand network so you can hire him
again
and again and again and you can call him
you don't
you know
say go tomorrow you can say
i need someone tomorrow and you have i
don't know 20 people on your reserve
and if someone can he will join and you
can create this you know huge pool of
people
who are qualified for the job you
already hire them once you know them
they know you
and it's not a new match it's it's
someone you're
it's part of your company
right
well what's going to be the hardest part
of this journey in your mind so you know
this company is 10 months old you're
already you're moving quickly a lot of
new experiences
looking to disrupt to market you
understanding the gen z mindset and
you're saying wow like we need to change
the way we deal with employment and we
create this you know buy conditional
contract that right now both sides are
losing at
what's going to be the hardest part for
you do you think both perhaps you as you
know the co-founder and ceo but also in
terms of just the company being able to
really do what it wants to do
wow so
there are many many difficult uh
you can
look at that in the market perspective
and i will say that
it's really hard to explain uh you know
people about a new concept so that's
really really hard and our market
marketing team and
sales department working really hard on
that on that matters
um
and from the from the company
perspective
our growth is
incredible i mean as you said the
company is
really young and
in
three months we became from five
employees into 35 employees wow and it's
it's incredible here to you know
it was a rapid growth and
i have to be honest sometimes it might
be really hard to you know
to maintain this
uh
you know
it's like a it's like a kid who's
growing really fast and you need to like
are you okay or what what to do with you
um
and
so i would say to
you know
to put the focus on the right things and
to
keep
you know to assemble the team that was
hard but also
to help them work together and align
together for this mission and the
mission is to to actually you know
i can say changing the world it will be
you know a cliche but
um but it's not just changing the world
it's
it's helping
millions of people because
they can't do what they want now they
can't
live the life they want to live and this
is what we're trying to to give them
did you choose to be an entrepreneur did
you choose you did you choose this
problem did you face it yourself how do
you get to
start this company
so
uh
as i mentioned before i worked in in
parallel cohen as an investment banker
and
you know my co-founder itai uh one day
called me and said that he has an idea
for startup
and i was this you know his startup guy
his go-to guy to the to the tech scene
uh and we started working together on
that and it was really hard to find a
good business model that that works for
this you know old product
uh and after i think a month or two
i just said listen we can't
we can't figure it out
uh but i have an old idea i'll send your
presentation and tell me what you think
because
i had a lot of fun to work with him and
it was the same
from his size
so uh
and then i think it was around six or
seven am you just call me and say
listen
the presentation is
but i love the concept we have something
to work on
uh and this is how we started that
actually uh
and this you know
basic concept we had
almost a year ago
in no time became a company and that's
uh
i don't know if it chose me or i chose
that uh
it just happened
well
i want to uh thank you for coming here i
think that
it's very fresh what you're doing and i
it's it's it may be hard to understand
for some people
and you're literally taking an
employment phenomenon that's been around
for thousands of years and and
rethinking the employee employer
relationship and how do we create a
win-win situation in a world where we
have a new generation that is very
equipped to make a good impact on
businesses and but maybe it's not in the
traditional nine to five nine to six job
maybe it's more on the on-demand this uh
this the shift and in the way that we're
thinking and and creating a win-win for
everybody and and and i think that the
flexibility that you're mentioning is is
a pivotal role here so sunir thank you
very very much for coming here i really
appreciate it stay safe stay healthy
thank you and best of luck with zeeb
i'll try
thank you very much
[Music]
you